foreign
well hey everybody uh glad to be back
today
um hope everybody has had a good
uh week off hope hope everybody had a
chance to go back
and relook at some stuff and uh well i'm
glad you guys see me
um but yeah i was able to get a lot done
uh sorry
for uh uh being gone um super excited to
get back to it so all right today
we are mainly going to be looking at
recursion
going to be really understanding how to
interact with the command line
you also may know it as the dos prompt
which is basically what i grew up
calling it the command line i remember
the first time i heard that i was like
what is the command line
uh and then actually somebody on twitter
hit me up uh for dictionaries and i was
like absolutely we could do dictionaries
because i was uh kind of wondering if
those two were going to round out
our time but if you're new here thanks
for joining us i'm sam
uh from python basics and
um i am partnering with free code camp
and doing an entire series on
uh the building blocks of python so all
right
let's just go ahead and get into it so
glad everybody's here
there are four four previous videos
um and i believe beau has made a
playlist
so after we get down here don't don't go
and jump over there but after we get
done here
you can go and check those out and then
also there's a link
to my channel and every single topic
that we have done here
there has been a micro video on that so
that is
that is our intro so all right recursion
what that is is basically it is when a
program
or a function calls itself until
completion and a perfect a perfect
example of a recursive function
is uh some sort of countdown
or in math factorial so let's just go
ahead and get into it
as everybody know uh what factorial
is has anybody ever seen
that so factorial
so we're gonna just go through
everything so basically the math of
factorial is if we were gonna do three
factorial in math
it would be three times
two times one so three factorial
is six and as you could only imagine
how quickly this goes up so if we were
to do
six factorial
well i appreciate that uh six factorial
so six
times five times four times three times
two
times one you could leave off the one
now there's also
one important thing about factorial it
took me a while to really kind of
wrap my head around this and understand
what
what why and how so
one factorial is is one
zero factorial is also one because you
still have one
set that's basically when i had somebody
explain it and then i think i
read the same thing a couple times so
even zero factorial was one
so that is important when we're going to
be starting to
build our uh function out
so let's go ahead and get to it so
before we get to our
recursive function i will actually want
us to build
a factorial function so let's
let's just do this
all right and that went the wrong way
but i hope everybody has had a good week
i see we have
uh some of our mainstays
back in chat so that is awesome glad to
have you guys here
i do not have a video um
on factorial i didn't want to get too
much into that math
but i'm sure you could go and search um
what is it math oh oh i'm trying to
think matt
mathfax.org i
i think is one of those things one of
the places
oh you can't post links okay yes the
uh bo is out he's usually at master
control
uh watching this so he is on vacation so
i am
i am in complete autopilot here so when
i hit the stream button
it came up and then so we're gonna be up
until i hit uh
in the stream so uh hope all goes well
hope uh my internet hangs in there it's
some bad wet
bad weather around here but all right um
yes oh yeah actually i saw the other day
that uh bo and then put up a nine al
nine hour algebra uh video
that is crazy there's i these two hour
live streams uh
take it out of me so um
and just fyi i'm not feeling that hot
this morning so
uh i think i can make it all two hours
but just if we cut it a little short i
want you guys
to know so all right our factorial
and so we need to figure out a way to
count down
track and go forward and then i want to
show you guys this
then we need to plan for if it's
negative so all right we're going to
have our total
we've got to have some sort of count now
when we're using multiplication
what happens so we need to plan for this
so if we multiply something so we're not
counting at zero
where our total needs to start at one so
when we multiply anything by one
we get that that we get that uh product
almost said sum
almost broke broke the biggest
okay so somebody does have yes so good
um i'm pretty good at math not
super super awesome no i i only
what you'll begin to notice is it i will
only speak to
uh what i feel extremely confident and
that's why and i've done
these basic uh tutorials
for now coming up on five years so but
again
when i that's why my channel only only
focuses
on uh python we've touched on some
outskirts of stuff but that i
i try to stay in my lane as much as
possible to
uh keep my
keep me out of trouble all right so
we're going to be doing something over
and over and over and over again until
a certain condition is met not a certain
number of times
yes certain number of times but that
that amount will change every time so
i could go and have it loop through take
the len
but do a range function on lin that gets
a little dicey when we have this awesome
tool
while so while
while x is greater than 0
then we're going to increment up
right and then also we're going to touch
on
uh we're going to actually build this
into
um how to find the
odds of a powerball and a little bit
with comma placement and a little bit of
f string and uh i like this lesson
because it has a lot of stuff in it so
all right
um i will try to stay on task so now
we're going to learn how
that we can increment up by
multiplication so then we're going to go
up and then we need to
we're going to multiply up
multiplication increment
and then we're also then going to then
decrement so check this out
because as we go we're crossing each
other
so if x was 5 then
we want to multiply we take our total
so then we start there our total is one
oops total equals one
then i'm gonna multiply increment that
up by five right
so then my total is five let me make
sure we don't have any good questions
okay all right so now
then then x was five
so then i need a way to then track this
so i'm going to decrement
x by one so then x is four
then i'm gonna go in
increment up multiplication by x
so now tote is 20
but then i need to come down one more
here so does this make sense
so as we're going through now this
is a little bit more labored but i want
you to wrap your head around what is
going on because
recursion can get a little bit more
dicey
and i really want you guys to see and
understand this
because as this goes through it it can
be very overwhelming
has everybody even heard of recursion i
just uh
jan you're always awesome and very
interactive
have you heard of recursion
still trying to figure out how long the
delay is in chat i know
okay cool all right so awesome uh this
isn't
this isn't too foreign but factorial is
an
awesome way for recursion
all right so now also there is one big
distinction that we need to also make
sure we understand
because right now if i were to print
oops
then when i get done i print
total or tote
and call what was i
doing
so then i have a list
let's get rid of these we'll test those
in a minute
for test
and tests wow
print
fact
don't know why i've got text on my mind
today
so all right all right
so now i have
a little bit of a problem and i did this
wrapping
this around to show you something
because with recursion i can't use
print i'm going to need to use return
sometimes the this can be
okay so and and that's absolutely fine i
remember the first time
i ran across it i think i was
i was in high school doing uh algebra
maybe
and i heard about it but all right so
this is an example of
returning none and when you use
recursion
it you cannot use print
because you're going to be creating
something and then using
it again so let's get
that part down now also this isn't very
perfect because and i just wanted to
show you this
and also check out what that's
8 12 18 and then 100.
so that is how big 100 factorial
is and how quickly python is able to to
do it
i remember one of the first things uh
well not the first thing but i think
java begins to have a problem after uh
13 factorial
if i if i recall just the way that its
building blocks
are so just one of those things how
uh python stands out all right so
that is a very makeshift
very bare bones beginner
um
beginner how to do factorial so now
we're going to
now we're going to clean this up quite a
bit
let's do this comment that out
any questions of how factorial works at
all
so all right now we are going to build
our factorial
recursively with recursion and
i remember because i think i did a
function and i was
uh had a run time error and i
inadvertently was calling it
on itself and i think it was a hello
function
when i was first starting so i
accidentally
uh did it or did a uh recursion
and it just hung up hung up hung up hung
up hung up
and then in this instance you will
literally be putting the function
inside the function so let's just go
ahead and let's move this down
so now we're just going to keep this
clean and we're going to use our
same wow
fact x
i think in this one i use m so
all right so now we need to
handle we're going to be really really
accurate here so
when i said factorial 0 is 1
we need to handle this so if
in
less than negative one
oops i'm sorry greater
greater than negative 1 then
we're going to do our two conditions of
if it's 0
or if it's greater than 0 there but
we're gonna
handle this first
negative all right so now we have a
nested condition
so this is how i want you to think about
it think about your number line
so it can handle a factorial can be
zero through positive
cannot be uh
oops yes
greater than negative one then we're
gonna do
then we're gonna check if it's zero
return one then everything else
follow through sorry like i said
a little out of it not feeling that
great today so now let's handle
if n equals zero then we're going to
return
one and just to remind you
in python whenever the
return is hit it comes completely out
just jumps ends ends everything it
becomes dead code after
return that was uh one of the little
nitty-gritty things that i finally ran
into so
everything dead you don't ever need a
break whenever you hit return
maybe you can just throw in a return if
you want to and
it just kills everything and everything
after the return is called dead code
all right i don't know why i have this
pin here
okay so now let's get
into it and i'm going to
lay this out so else
return and i knew i spelled it wrong
because it didn't go
orange or yellow i call that orange
all right so n times and it's
literally this simple but
we're going to talk about it n
minus 1 going forward
so all right here we go
let's get over here let's make sure i
have this sized right
okay good let's get here to make sure
anybody got any questions so far
that's a good way to say it so all right
so if you want output
print prints things to the screen but it
returns
none it does not create anything so
most of the time you're going to be
creating
a variable and wanting to use it later
so you can literally take a function
pass an information assign that to a
variable
and you have created you've created that
information
print just puts it out to the screen
print prints out anything you want it to
print
so when i go when i'm gonna go and run
this
like when i was up here and i wrapped i
did this to kind of foreshadow
i wrapped um
where was it i wrapped my
right here i wrapped that with print and
that's when it returned none
okay so now i'm gonna leave this
here and nothing's going to happen
it's returning and creating actually i
may show you
well i don't want to get too far into
the woods off this
um maybe next week we can just do
things on print and return for a good
good
solid section but yes this is what the
takeaway here is
return creates something and then you
can take that
and assign it to whatever you want if
you just wanted to print it out to the
screen
great but if more than likely
you want to then link those things
together and you could take a function
yep that's exactly it because it
returned
it it returned something so you needed
to go and link that information and
assign it to a variable
and then there's going to be times where
it's going to say in place return
none you cannot assign that to a new
variable
there's documentation on uh
is it sort believe it's
i think i believe it's a list sort yes
you'd need to make a cop
that's why you sorted go back and look
at the documentation on that
that's why it says return none in place
you cannot
assign a new variable so that's why
these distinctions are very very very
important at the beginning of your
python journey
is to understand the difference because
you will get hung up
on things so all right
yep that is exactly it
and that's why i love this so much so
all right so basically
this is what i want you to think about
so it's going to be going
in or five
five times then
this is how this is so then it's gonna
go parentheses
then 5 minus
then it's going to go again
then times five
minus two
and as this goes through it's going to
be
and then there then
it will wrap again
then it wraps these two
there we go then
five minus three
then it wraps those around
so it goes down and down and down i
think this goes right
there there but you're starting to get
the idea so
this nests and nests and nests
until it gets down to so then that
is another factorial inside of that then
it's a factorial inside of that
then a factorial inside of that then a
factorial inside of that until it
exterminates down to there so
let's get rid of this
so now now let's
run this all right we have our tests
right here right
and then let's do zero and negative two
let's add those back now why is this
going to fail
i gave a hint why does this fail
okay that's not too big of a delay
all right i made a passing comment
anybody remember
because
it returns
does not
i did not have a print so now this is
also why recursion a recursive function
needs to be returning needs to be
creating because then this
this will not work or you have to get
extremely over complicated but we're
making our progress here
so then i have my negative i have my
uh 1 of course
equals 1 then my 0 equals one because it
is still a set
of zero so it is one set equaling one
and then i have my uh
my catch right here else return
negative all right so now
now let's jump into something that i do
like the math on
and it shows so i know you there are a
lot
a lot of us a lot of individuals on
today
that are outside of the country outside
of the united states
does anybody know uh how the united
states
does our lottery um with the little
with the little bouncy balls and they go
in and then they pick pick a
pick a bouncy ball and how the odds work
on that
has has anybody seen that because i
don't know how much to go into it
because
now now we're going to spin off and
we're going to use
a factorial to
then figure out the odds of
winning a combination of numbers
anybody anybody ever heard of
heard of uh heard of that all right the
stream looks good
alright well cool well we will we will
get into it so all right
let's see we don't need these anymore so
the way that
the odds the way that the odds work for
this
uh lottery
powerball and here's what was genius
about
the lottery officials of what they did
so when i was growing up
there were have no idea okay
so basically it's a big tub
and 50-something balls go
go into this and they each have a number
on it and they bounce around and people
buy tickets and they wager each ticket
is worth
i think two dollars now and they can
either let the computer pick
six random numbers or you can go in
and pick six random numbers and people
tend to
have a methodology they wage they they
pick the same numbers it's birthdays
it's
street names but when you have
50 balls bouncing around and you have to
pick them now you do not have to pick
them in
order just anything because then if you
had to pick them in order
i actually don't i think i saw the math
on that but all right to give you an
idea
of how the math on this works is if you
have
50 50 balls to pick from
then then you have
and you pick six of them so here's the
math on this
it's 50 factorial
let's let me make sure i have this right
then
it's 50 factorial times
oh shoot i have it here but it's uh
50 factorial 49 factorial 48 factorial
47 factorial 46
45 yes
so that is the how exponential
this is and you go through
oh cool uh free code camp has a new
supporter
that's awesome well thank you very much
so
now we're going to take this new tool
that we have and we're going to
yes yes it is absolutely
now it's not as complicated as having to
have it in order
which i don't uh like i said
math we can tiptoe out of math pretty
quickly i'm i'm good
right up until the beginnings of
calculus but
i digress here now here was the genius
part
of what lottery officials did they added
a powerball a whole whole only section
and what they did is they removed a
number you only had to pick
five numbers then a powerball and
everybody
actually thinks that
that is easier and it's actually harder
so
it was 50 factorial 49 factorial
48 that's
47.
now here's where it gets weird so 47
that's
46 45.
so that was the old way one two
three four five six so see how that
number's smaller so when they removed
this
and then they gave a whole other bin of
50 more numbers
so it actually goes back to
50 factorial i think what it is so they
actually made the odds more challenging
but everybody who is
gambling and buying these lottery
tickets they think they only have to
pick
five numbers and this other one is
easier it was genius when i first
had a math teacher assign it to me so
now
we're going to use our python knowledge
to actually calculate and build a
function
of how in the world to calculate
the powerball odds and it's actually
quite interesting so let me
get the right one oh and we got and if i
can hang in there we got some very cool
stuff
with the
oh where did it go
i thought i had it right here sorry guys
all right
let's bring this over here
did i really not save it
all right well here's here's the math
that i
pulled out
so this is this is what the math is
because then you pick one
and you go forward and the this is
this is it right here and we're going to
be putting this into a
function and then we're going to learn
some other cool stuff
that i don't think we have gone over yet
okay i did have it i had it on another
screen
i should have put this all in one place
all right so now what we're going to do
is we're going to build a function and
we're actually going to use
uh some i think somebody's got a couple
comments
all right observe
so we're gonna use a default argument
we're going to do
a we need to have a loop a while loop
so let's get in here def
odds
almost pick and power
so if if it's going to have power or not
all right has anybody ever seen
this before what i'm doing right here
everybody understand this anybody
because it this is super important and
we're just going to go over it
because if one of you if you have not
seen my video from yesterday on my
channel
if you have the question somebody else
has the question
so i i'm usually pretty thorough
uh yeah d uh it's a default argument
so optional argument default argument
so it is you have to
pass these two you do not have to pass
in
power it is already set for you on false
all right so the way we're doing this
is and we're going to use a
inter number of
regular balls
number of balls
picked yep
and if
if they are using
a powerball so basically you
will be asked
for the number
of powerballs so basically
this function is for anybody
who could because there are different
lotteries in each state then there are
some
that have states that share so
you could take this function and apply
this to
any lottery and then you could
understand the odds that you're dealing
with and you could figure out
if you're into gambling you can figure
out which ones have the better odds
so all right now i'm going to show you
something
uh who remembers us looking at the math
module anybody remember us looking at
the math module
because i like um
i had a couple of tv teachers and they
explained it look
i will show you how to use the shortcut
way but i need you to
prove that you can understand where it's
coming from
so the math module actually has a
factorial built in for us
so i also wanted to show you recursion
but
there's a tool already out there most
everything
that i'm showing you there's always a
tool
out there but if you start using
something you don't understand how it
works especially under the hood
of all kinds of things you can get into
trouble
uh with you might be like somebody was
just getting something to return
or they thought they were getting
something to return and they weren't it
was only printing out to the screen
so if you don't understand under the
hood and how it works
you can you can get into a little bit of
dusty things
so all right let's peek inside our math
our math uh module so der
on math helps if i close this out
all right and it's factorial
they're right there so we're going to do
a shortcut
from math
import factor
fact
all right does everybody understand this
alias
and this import line right here so this
is a shortcut
because right now this is my
main level math and if i wanted to get
to factorial
i would need to use math dot factorial
then pass in 3
and i get 6 to come out
but now if i were to
if i were to do this from
math import
factorial then i only have to type in
fact
oriole 3
but then if i alias this
now all i have to do is
type in three and i get it so that is
that
so if you are lazy and don't like to
type
a lot and you will come up with a fast
way to do it
you and i can be friends okay so here we
are
okay now there's a couple more things
that i need to show you which are very
very good
so our result is going to be
like i said we're just going to do this
return
and here's our math so it's
balls uh
two two parentheses
then division
and you wanna get all these parentheses
so you can make sure you have order of
operation
order of operation pemdas i remember i
don't think i actually committed pemdas
to memory until
i started teaching python and i was
volunteering at my kids
schools because they uh one of
my kids very nice math teachers
asked for some help and i actually got a
python lesson
out of it so that's kind of an example
so all right
pemdas parentheses exponent
multiplication division adding and
subtracting
so those are the order of operations
that's the rank
that the rank and importance and the
order you need to do first
parentheses trump exponents exponents
trump
uh multiplication and division
and then then you do adding and
subtracting
but you do parentheses that is what you
do first then you do those other
variations they go in order and
uh order of importance and uh
set set rules and python oops
sorry guys that was probably really loud
those are the rules and python is built
upon those rules so
very important that we know them now now
we need to
handle so that's our output but we need
to handle a couple things here
so this right here so no matter what
we're either going to be multiplying
this by one
i'm sorry to hear that jan is anybody
else having any
any other buffering issues uh
or is that um because i
it looks like the stream is good on
my part uh is anybody else having any
issues
okay good because like i said i had to
reboot my my router before i got started
today because my upload was
atrocious so i'm trying to make sure you
guys don't have any issues
okay so now we need to handle some
things
and one of the first things we need to
handle has is this
has anybody ever seen uh
the the value for bullion
so that's what it is but has anybody
ever seen a value
anybody ever seen this
anybody ever seen that where
true act true and false actually have a
value to them
so i remember when i saw that and i
thought
that was the coolest thing so we're
actually going to take this technique
and we're going to utilize it right here
so this i remember when i
saw this and was going through it and
somebody did an example and i was like
i know how i can do this and it's going
to be so cool
so all right
first if
if the power is
if there is no powerball we're just
gonna multiply this by one and go on
about our day so there is no powerball
so so here's
here's the balls did i close this out
let's see got one
something about that didn't feel like it
got the right number
one one two one two one one two
okay there we go
okay then
so now we need to set this
p underscore ball to 1.
so that was that was the way that i do
this so we can have this just on
one nice little condition
so if this is false this is just set to
one
going about your day so now watch this
then if power
if power then take input
powerball equals int
input enter
number of
power balls
close this one close that out close that
out
so what i'm doing let's see
so what i'm doing here you could say
does power equal true
but i don't need to be that
this is very passive so if i turn this
true
this is true and then
it moves on so right now it's false
so when you have this you could
literally
have this go through and make this
i could i could make this a
p ball right
so it's already going through
and set this so i wanted to get your
guys's mind to wrap around this
so if power so i could
i could play i could play into this
where
power could go back and forth
and then if we go on
so i just wanted to show you that
because i remember the first time i saw
this so
if this is false i don't have to say if
if power is true do this i literally
just come here
and go this is false
just come down here and multiply that
and i have this
just b1 and move on about our day so now
this returns so i need to do
print odds
and i'm going to pass
okay good you can't see that alert um
i'm going to pass in would i say 50
which would say what example do i use
oh and then we need to do our formatting
because where our eyes are used to
seeing
parentheses i'm sorry commas
so 69 balls
six and let's just close that out right
now
so let's run this
spelling is a problem
so let's see
so 719 million 264
832 to 1 are the odds
of winning the lottery
with 69 balls and
six choices so now
now let's change this up and go
true so now
enter number of powerballs 26.
so now
it has gone it is even worse
so now we need to all right
i clicked off so now we need to
oh very cool we got an uh we have
another uh supporter so that's very
awesome
well thank you guys all right
so now i want to show you how to add a
comma
into python's output
oh that's supposed to be six not that
there we go because now it goes
see now it's a billion see how that one
little tweak
of adding a fresh batch of batch of
numbers
goes in so now it's over a billion to
one
all right but i have to go through and
highlight or i do
you may not have to you may be able to
see that so first i'm going to show you
how to do this with old string format
and then we'll jump into
wow f string all right
so now uh
so boom
it can be i was showing that you could
go
and make and assign
oh okay the powerballs are are their own
little set
of numbers and it was to kind of trick
people into realizing that they had a
brand new set
of numbers to go in so it was you have
this one container where five balls are
picked out of
then you had this auxiliary container
and you had an additional brand new
batch
of numbers to pick from that started
back over
and it actually increased the
probability
because they are more
there's there's more numbers everybody
thinks that it was going to be
easier because it was a its own small
container
but it was actually just adding another
set of numbers to have a larger
factorial
problem to it so that's why
this little this little trick that they
did
made it worse but
somebody who's not as in depth and again
we're heading we're probability and
statistics we're heading
quickly out of my element but i i was
able to really wrap my head around this
this math problem and it was one of the
basic ones that i really got
a lot out of with uh probability
uh the last number needed to win a
lottery must be the last number chosen
by the player
i don't know exactly if i understand
that but um
no it the the powerball idea
was to add uh add a
larger probability to it but it actually
people thought it was easier to pick
because then they only had to pick
five numbers out of the main container
which with another one so all right
let's let's learn how to use a
let's see yeah dot
format let's bring this in
and there we go sorry i'm going to show
you this
the format way and then i'm going to
show you
actually let's get rid of this so we
don't
there so the way that python has this
let's see where to go
it's literally this simple
all right so python understands that
this
i'm wanting to place a comma
in our standard grouping of numbers
all right
oh yes yes yeah okay yes i that then
that
will be yes the pow the powerball is
chosen last
and it's kind of for a more exhilarating
choice yes the power the powerball is
chosen last and it's you usually a red
a a red number but again i don't i don't
play the lottery there are people who
could
there's all over here in the states
there are
uh we like to gamble a lot we i i don't
partake in it i don't judge anybody who
does
but there are all kinds of uh
gambling and lottery and things like
that but all right
this right here will print
everything into a nice comma
setup so now i didn't have to go through
and do this now this is how
the f string works and i like to show
you actually we'll leave this here
we'll copy it that's what we'll do
and yes i don't like copying and it's
literally just
like this oops
and we place this just in front of it
and then get rid of everything else
so let's go over
all right so now with f string
it is still this setup and you just
that's the
what you want to have happen to this
output
so there we go so that is an f string
format
for adding a comma to numbers and this
is a string format
layout so there we go
i don't know i thought this was absurdly
cool of how simple and clean and clear
in python it is to just add commas to uh
numbers with placement so all right any
questions about that before we move into
the command line
who knows what command line is or dos
prompt or
terminal i think in apple uh terminal
so i'm going to show you two ways to get
to it
the easy way the same way or
the more challenging way so uh
python just understands this that this
is
uh inside this inside the formatting
rules
it understand
well that is you would have to do that
manually
so with in in
uh i can't remember if i've done that
so what we do oh i do actually have a
video and i need to find it somewhere
uh how to format um
a telephone number so that has
three three and four i'll have to find
that
but that's a hyphen but
python understands because it's
consistent with numbers
that you're going to have and it
understands exactly what this means
it's a it's a basically it's a setting
so
um we we would have to use that i can't
remember
we're using regular expression but you
know what this is why i love this
interactive you guys are so smart let me
make let me make some notes for next
week
so we're gonna do telephone and i think
i have one for social security numbers
too
i think so telephone
and social security number
social security number all right uh
and actually somebody told me asked me a
question about
our social security numbers because i
think they were from new zealand
and their numbers are actually in
batches
and uh to know when you were born
here in the united states our social
security number
is built on geography so the first ones
are uh
what state you are in and then
and then then the group and then it
recycles so
we have uh and then just like our area
code
we have three digits for the area code
the exchange and then
four numbers so you can get the idea of
how big and complicated
how big and complicated these numbers
can get over and over and over again so
each
each area code can have a certain number
of
prefixes and then every prefix can have
ten thousand
combinations because they're uh numbers
of
four so ten times ten times ten times
ten
ten thousand that's what is so cool
because like i remember that i got
really easy
so when you have a three digit number
number of choices times number of
choices times number of choices
one thousand or just
when you do that because you have zero
zero zero
and nine nine nine okay all right so
command line
uh go down to your search
bar type in cmd and you get your command
prompt
you can't see that sorry i got this
sized up just like this
and you type in cmd
and you get your command prompt or
for our example or what we're going to
be doing
is pull up your python file
your folder where you have all of your
python
and typically it's going to be in your
app uh
app data local programs python then
whichever variation of python you have
let's get out of that so right now all
of this is in
my python38-32 and then literally you
just go
to the search bar type in command line
i remember the first time i saw this i
thought it was so awesome
you literally go to the directory
that you're in and that's vital to what
we're about to start doing
so we need to do a couple of things
we need to understand how python
interacts with the command line before
we can really do anything
all right cool i'm hanging in there we
got an hour in i think we're doing
pretty good
are you guys you guys hanging in there
you guys are doing pretty good
so if you're new here it's top of the
hour so if you're getting getting all
set up
i'm sam uh with python basics
and i live stream on free code camp
on tuesdays uh for two hours
and we go through uh it's a
very large very vast very try to be as
in-depth as possible about the basics of
python programming and
down in the description below is a link
to
my channel which has every single thing
that we cover on here
i'm literally just re-going through
all the videos i've done before i
started a live stream
on my channel to have a longer format
and then free code can't reached out to
me and
i thought it was an awesome idea to just
help more people
i love python i've been studying it for
a while now
and i've been teaching it for about five
years
and i just think it's phenomenal so all
right right now
we are on we are in the command
prompt and i have
so when you type in python now
because i'm in that folder i get it now
i also have my path
set up and if you're not sure how to do
that
i guess what i have a video for that on
my channel uh we can maybe look into it
if you have a
great deal of problems but literally now
i am running
i am in python just
just like this oops didn't need to do
that
so let's come up let's come up here and
i want to show you
okay i promise i will stop doing that at
some point
but literally 8.1 this is the exact
version this is the shell that i'm
running
right here all right so
we need to learn how python
and your computer are going to interact
so we're going to learn about the cis
module
now i'm going to show you this this is
the only module you can't touch
python says no we're not going to let
you
get to cis
and but the os
brings in cis and this is as close as
you can get
but you can also bring in sis
all right so bleh
so the way that we interact with the
command line
let me go through i think i got some
pretty cool notes and i want to make
sure i go through this
so the way that this is is i'm
going to look at help
on sis.org
v
if no argument is given built
mutable sequence a list
built in a list so now let's i forget
how many times i got to go through this
all right so then i'm going to back out
of here
i forget that okay uh quit
cls all right if i lost anybody yet
is everybody good still so now what i'm
going to do
is
copying close this out
so here's my here's my file
so import
sys print sys dot
arg v does anybody recognize arg
v args arguments and then
argv variables so now if i run this
i want to show you what comes what comes
out
so now i could do i need to save this
and i knew i didn't save it if i shown
everybody this
let me let me do this
my asterisk right up here i know this
isn't saved because i have an asterisk
i love working with young people and i
ask them if they
press f5 and they say yes and they say
it's not working and i can walk up
see here's here's the trick this is why
you're so lucky
to have me i have screwed up every
single way possible
so i know where all the pitfalls are
that's my
that's what my superpower is uh i'm not
that smart
i'm slow but my superpower is i can mess
something up and then i learn from it so
all right i did not save that so what
i'm doing right here is
now i gotta go free
code camp so i'm calling the file
free codecamp.py how
are you
uh oh i completely forgot that
all right
doesn't like the spaces so we're gonna
use our temp we're gonna steal
import system want to get into that
print i was using my temp file today
so print arg
arg v
and then control sleep error transition
and then we're going to go
temp underscore
one all right
so python temp underscore one dot py
how are u
so what this does is it returns
it returns a list right here so sys.org
v takes in everything
splits it but completely ignores python
so i also
i love this example because
since we're already here in the
interpreter or we're in the file and
python understands
that this is a our computer understands
that
this is a dot py file so i can just run
this and this prints out i want to draw
your attention to this this is a list
but this is the absolute path
i think we've talked about absolute and
relative
this is relative because i'm in right
here so i want to show you right
i'm sitting right
there and then i'm relative
to this path directory
subdirectory path directory subdirectory
all all the same
so this is going to spit out
all of the arguments excluding this
because this understands
this is the program we're going to use
so this is a list
this is important to what we're about to
do so we're going to take a condition
and understand what we have and then
move forward
so what we're going to do we don't need
this anymore
so i'm going to comment that out because
we know not to delete anything
so it's a list so if
lynn of sys.org v
greater than one
print
uh hello
sis dot our v
one
else print
a standard awesome hello world
bam all right
so let's go through didn't mean to do
that
see how many times i hit f um
so temp py
all right so let's go through this
so on this input
python takes it takes all of it right
excluding if we pass in python it knows
it goes hey
you want that you want that program go
on from there
all right and then everything thereafter
put this in a list just set it off the
side put it into a list if you want to
deal
deal with it great if you don't i still
have it
so what i'm saying is
i'm telling python hey if this list
is greater than one i want you to then
do this and we're going to print out
hello
and index the list at index
1 place that here
and hello so now if i were to do this
i get hello sam so if it's greater than
come to the list index 1 so then also
print just so we can see
uh print
actually we just want to do sys.rt
save
so just so you can start to wrap your
head around this
i'd we can look at that i know there's i
know it's in here
[Music]
i know i've had it with numpy i don't
know with math
i don't know if the math module i don't
know if you guys see in chat
uh if it's looking for trigonometry i
can't remember
if math has it but i know numpy has it
all right so i just wanted to do this
and print this out
okay it is because i know oh
okay don't know numpy numpy is one of
the really big building blocks
of it was the beginnings of it
then people came along and added to that
so all right
let's get through this and then we'll
chat and actually we may be wrapping
this up
i'm really not feeling that great so all
right
let's uh let's at least finish this out
and we'll see if it passes or not
okay so we had our standard
um where we took in our
our list our arguments from the command
line our sys.org v
right our list
right up here anything typed on the
prompt
excluding our program to run so it takes
that
turns us into the absolute path then any
other things split
on the white spaces all right so
i took i gave it the file
and i gave it another bit of information
and argument
if it was longer than one so this has
len of two this is index zero
this is index one so i've had this print
out
so now now let's do this with more than
one
and then maybe we'll talk about numpy in
a few minutes i'm going to try to make
it
to 10 30 and then if this
passes we'll we'll move on all right
so there we go all right
so now i want to take in
two let's see
if of if
when cis.org v
equals two
print so we'll do this in a minute
we'll go over this real slow print
f
hello
sis.org argv
then our slice
close that out then lf
blend.sys
v equals three
print
hello did i close this
out nope
v then one
close close
i hear you are
close close close close
else print
hello world
all right save
so here we go this hello world
sam and then 43.
so let's go let's go through this
oops
i'm so out of it today i'm sorry guys
not gonna be allowed back all right so
let's go through this
really really slow so there's my
there's my list of
one two three one two three
then one two
one so because
i passed in just one argument
this scenario i just get hello world
just pass in the file name
then i pass in my
file name and my name equals two
do this file name
name age
three arguments do this indexing
with name and then age
all right
uh well okay this is very fluid and you
guys are here to
to learn python so let's take a minute
and just peek at math
jan did you say that uh
uh it does have some
i guess i can't remember yeah okay
um because the question
now are you referring so yeah it has uh
sine cosine tangent are those
are they and then even degrees
do you see that have you run have you
run dur on math
and then you run help on math dot
cosine and return the cosine
and it's measured in radians okay
okay i thought i can get away with using
yeah oh a note
numbai is actually more for
matrices and things like that really
high-end math
uh but i knew i knew it had some
and uh law
uh yeah you should be able to and i mean
it's got uh i knew it had pie and power
so
here we need to while we're tiptoeing
around this i want to show you this so
we got help let's do help on math
301 lines so the only problem with
a couple of these i do not like
and i don't complain about document kit
documentation very much
but there are some times where
all right so we need we need to talk
about this
and this is a better one
so you see these right here and you
think all of these are
all of these are methods summer
attributes
okay so method you have to call with the
parentheses
i can't even tell if i'm in focus okay
you need to call with the parentheses
and call them
now these right down here are attributes
so you do not you just call them okay
all right these have value
all right so you do not need to have and
you typically have them when they're
down here in the data
so these these how you did these are how
you differentiate
attributes and methods i don't know if
i've actually explicitly said that
it took me forever to realize that i was
like why why when why how do you know to
not
use the dot or the or not to use the
parentheses and when to use the
parentheses
they are typically
right down here so all right let's see
where i am
with notes to get us this close to uh
12 does did does uh the command uh to
the
sysdark v does all this make sense
before we move on
all right well very cool all right let's
just go ahead and get into it
so actually we had a somebody on twitter
reached out to me last night i was
putting out there that
was going to be back today and got
quite a few response likes and retweets
and thought it was very cool i think
beau
even uh retweeted and liked um
uh the tweet so i thought that was very
cool and uh
also for those of you who are here and
have gone over to my channel i just want
to tell you guys
thank you very much because uh i've
passed 3500 subscribers and that is very
humbling
for me so all right i just want to tell
you guys thank you i love this
love doing it so much and um just for
you guys to
hang out with me and choose to spend
your time
learning from me is extremely humbling
so
all right dictionaries
they are absolutely awesome
jan you are very welcome i appreciate
all the time and support
uh you're always here you're very very
vocal and i really appreciate that
because that keeps me on task and
knowing that i'm going
in the right direction so all right
what is a dictionary do you guys
uh just give me a feeler uh
it's a it's another type of container
with python and
so variables are variables um and where
where things become powerful is the type
of container with which
they stay are contained in
and in a dictionary
are the curly brackets square brackets
are lists curly brackets
are dictionaries so type
d dictionary
and then we run uh
help on
dictionary 121 lines you're good
all right aha
you can iterate through it and this is
where it becomes
very very powerful
key value so now
and there's also one thing that is very
awesome
about uh dictionaries
you can have so one
one of the three rules in python is
a variable
cannot be a number excuse me
can't start with a number so it can't
just be a soul number it can it can end
with a number it can't contain a number
but it can't
just be a number or start with a number
so
but a key can and the way that you
these are associated is
so if i were to uh
d equals 1
sam so now
d the key 1 is associated with sam so
this
is a perfect example of
let's say you have a situation and
you're going to be counting things and
you have
no idea none whatsoever
how many of whatever you're counting
people like you you're you you're gonna
have people come coming to a game
you have no idea how many people are
gonna show up a dictionary is one of
those tools
that you have this container and you
just go through
and you increment and count and go up
from there
and then have any information associated
with it
so before we get too far into it let's
just do
some simple things
and then we will
there we go all right
all right dictionaries
all right so
i want to look at this
and then the other so i showed you
this okay that's one way
d then
t t
so type
d is a dictionary type t it's also a
dictionary so you have two
you have two ways and we're gonna
there's a little bit of foreshadowing
of how we can get through to this
so all right i already showed you this
so one
and then now also i want to show you
another way so
d now this
that can i bet actually i know exactly
where you were coming from
this is where it gets a little odd is
that the key
is wrapped in a bracket so i bet that's
where you got that from
and that is a little confusing so the
main list
excuse me the main dictionary is wrapped
in curly brackets
but to get to a key to get out the value
you do need to use brackets so i bet
that's exactly what you were doing
sorry uh what was my main example
that i don't want that anymore we're
done with that
so we have sam
oh my goodness i'm just going through
these
notes oops
there we go so
i just saw that the last time or the
original
lesson on this was two years ago because
i was 41 when i did this because that's
what my age was then so all right
so here's my key
now i want to show you this so then you
call this
like this
close this out so my key
i'm passing in this key to this
dictionary
and get this value all right
now let me show you this
so this is a way you kind of add one and
then here's
just creating fruit equals
bracket banana
close that out so you get your colon
then i have three of these comma
apples i have one of these
and grapes
close that out i got two grapes
all right so then i call fruit
so then i get my key
a value and the whole dictionary just
like that
now i want to show you this
for i in
fruit print
i you only get out the key
all right when you're looking at it so
lynn
of fruit how many keys are there
okay now you can literally
because if you've messed around with
json at all so that's just pulling
information
out uh off web uh web pages you're doing
inquiry
so to understand how a dictionary works
you need to understand
and the example we're about to do is
putting a dictionary inside a dictionary
i believe
and i want to show you this so but i
also want to show you how to pull
everything out so we're going to run dir
not fur
dir
i should not have got out of bed today
sorry everybody uh dur
on fruit
let's see i got keys
i got i got
items i got values
okay so all right let's
let's see let's see what keys does
so we got fruit dot keys
all right so i got banana apples
grapes okay fruit
fruit dot values let's see what these
are
aha so three one two
all right what does items do
food dot items
oh wait a second
all right so this is this is kind of
cool
this is kind of cool so now okay okay
okay i got
four for i in
ryan fruit
i got
i just got the keys
but if i do help okay okay okay so
i'm going to get this help on items
let's add a fruit
items all right i get items
uh what do i want to show you i'm going
to show you
this is what i want to show you right
here so
it's actually in the documentation
just like this so now when you get
items here
so our items comes out how did items
come out
huh so i get a tuple so this is kind of
like unpacking
so now i need to unpack this so
key value
and dot items
sorry i thought somebody was here so i
unpacked this
so key value
so now when i run this
all right
i can tweak this a little bit more
uh
i have
v
three
so what am i doing
okay so you can swap these around so i
know in my key value pair
i'm going to get the key first then the
value
key first then the value i have to
unpack that and assign it so
if you're anything like me i got it i
got to unpack it put it the way that i'm
going to see it
and then i literally then can just come
through here
and place it wherever i want to
all right
let's see so all right guys
like i was saying i think we can pick up
here
i i'm not feeling that
hot we got 90 minutes in so um
i think that is a great stopping point
uh sorry everybody for
cutting this short and i'll extend my
my apologies to to bow in them
but so super glad to be back please
i love all the feedback i think we got
so we're gonna do
more with uh
yes absolutely
um so glad to have so many people here
um well i i appreciate that i
i thought i would get going and get okay
but um just um
nope but we'll be back next week
uh absolutely love the um hit me up on
twitter
or uh with ideas
because or go to my my channel
um and see the things that we did you
can go to the playlist of the first 100
or 200
because we have not even made it out of
the first 100 videos
from my channel so the idea of these
live streams is going back over those
so then you're able to go back and
search for micro videos
on all of these topics now there is some
things in here that we have
that i have not expanded upon but um
well i'm glad you guys are getting out
of it
uh something and i'm very humbled that
you guys come and spend
uh all this time uh with me
so um you guys have a great week
great rest of your day and we got some
things brewing
so that we can we can uh always be in
contact there's a there's
some folks helping me out but as always
guys
i greatly appreciate you guys watching
hope you got something out of it and i
will see you guys next week
bye guys